g7 leaders are heading into the final
day of their summit in the French resort
of Biarritz today today's meeting are
expected to focus on climate change and
the fires burning in the Amazon now over
the weekend the leaders discuss a range
of world problems from global trade to
brexit and the war in Ukraine but the
gathering took an unexpected turn on
Sunday
French president de manuel McCraw
invited the Iranian Foreign Minister
the show of bonhomie at the end of day
two concealed any tension there may have
been between Donald Trump and Emmanuel
macron over a surprise visit by the
Iranian Foreign Minister Mohammad Javad
Zarif had flown into Barretts for talks
with macron as he ramped up efforts to
salvage the 2015 nuclear deal the US has
sanctions on Zarif Trump did not attend
the talks and the White House said it
was surprised by the meeting afterwards
Zarif tweeted that the road ahead is
difficult but worth trying still it
remains unclear whether president macron
has succeeded in calming the deepening
troubles between Iran and the u.s.
Sunday's most tangible achievement came
after a meeting with African leaders and
the announcement of a new plan to help
countries in the Sahel region fight
terrorism today it's clear the situation
is urgent this is a race against
terrorism
we cannot say right now that the
security situation is getting better
therefore we must act quickly Germany is
very invested in this important
initiative and we will dedicate the full
breadth of our resources to it on der
the plan g7 nations will help African
countries strengthen their police and
security forces g7 leaders also said
they were nearing a deal to help Brazil
tackle forest fires raging in the Amazon
but there was a little sign of progress
on the key issue of trade alarmed g7
allies have so far failed to get
President Trump to take their side and
ditch tariffs in his escalating trade
war with China even if by the end of
Sunday's talks Trump was putting a
friendly face on the meeting let's go
straight to Biarritz now ndw spent
Riegert he's covering the g7 summit for
us there good morning to you
Bant could we see an agreement today on
some kind of action plan to put out
these fires raging in Brazil's Amazon
I wouldn't call it an action plan
exactly because the g7 is not going to
put firefighters or something else on
the ground Emmanuel macron the French
president only said yesterday night that
there are clothes to come to an
agreement to offer financial and some
logistical help to the Brazilians but
the Brazilian President balsa narrow a
right-wing nationalist refused any help
from the g7 so far and the European
Union tried to put some pressure on
Boston our by saying we will not sign a
free trade agreement with Brazil on the
table in the framework of the macro
sewer and but on the other hand the
American president Donna Trump said he
will boost trade with Brazil in the
upcoming months though there's a slight
contradiction at this summit and this is
not the only one okay the US president
also wants to talk about Iran Syria
North Korea and to do that he says
Russia is essentially wants to bring
Russia back into the fold with the g7 he
made a push for that did that get any
support only the outgoing populist
Italian prime is the contr had somewhat
of support for this idea all the others
refused the idea to let bloody Mir Putin
the Russian president back in into this
very exclusive club because it's a club
of democracies and they say as long as
Putin is in Crimea and xìng this
peninsula he cannot come back and u.s.
president Trump argued for Putin and he
said he must be back because we need him
there was a fierce exchange of arguments
over dinner last night and next year
when mr. Trump will be the head of the
g7 he has all the opportunities and the
right to invite mr. Putin as a guest and
many here think he will do that okay how
did the u.s. president respond to the
surprise visitor at this summit the
Iranian Foreign Minister well Donald
Trump said no comment
only these two words which is unusual
for him actually and that shows there
was some confusion about the this
surprise guest
nobody know exactly what the French
president
McCrone wanted to achieve by inviting
mr. Suri fear to beer it's in the end
sir I've only met McCraw and some
officials from Germany and Britain but
he didn't speak to any American official
so far sir Eve himself rejected to meet
Americans so there was no progress
substantial progress in talks and the
tensions are still on between the United
States and Iran about the nuclear deal
so it was a coup by Mac Rome but it
didn't go far okay ban thanks so much
what much more from the last day of the
g7 summit in Biarritz for now bad thanks
very much